- This is dreams we're talking about.
We're talking about dreams.
(inspiring music)
So many people are asking me like how,
how do I live my dream Gary?
I don't have time,
I have mortgages and bills and
responsibilities and my job.
I don't have time for my side hustle,
my Twitch channel, my Instagram account,
my Shopify store selling hoodies?
And I keep getting to this new place
which is talk to me about your bills.
Like why'd you buy an
apartment that stretches you?
Why's your car so fancy?
Why do you need the new Gucci every time?
Why are you going out Thursday,
Friday and Saturday night?
Why are you going to Coachella?
Why are you going to
Avengers opening night
and buying the biggest
piece of popcorn and candy?
The answer to all of your questions
is not how much money you make
or how much time you have,
it's what you're spending your money on.
Why do you want the
newest pair of Yeezy's?
Why?
(inspiring music)
You're not entitled to your dream.
You're entitled,
nobody's entitled to be an amazing dancer.
Nobody that tours the world
and gets to dance and open for Beyonce
and make 580 a year and fucking live it
and go to fucking Monaco
on the fucking weekends,
it's not how it works.
Everybody starts at zero,
some people start at different places
but anybody who does it for themselves
has to sacrifice.
Yes,
move.
My city's expensive.
Move.
Like my car payments are high.
Sell your car and buy a piece of shit car,
take the bus.
This is dreams we're talking about.
We're talking about dreams.
We're talking about I want
to be a professional gamer.
We're talking about I
want to get paid $200,000
to give speech.
We're talking about
shit that isn't normal.
(inspiring music)
Dreams require sacrifices.
People don't want to sacrifice.
Some reason, DNA, parenting, circumstance,
I'm on the extreme end
of everything's my fault.
Nobody owes me shit.
I shouldn't get anything
unless I bleed for it.
(inspiring music)
It's one big framework, DRock,
of self esteem, lack of
self esteem/insecurity,
entitlement or accountability.
It's these huge things.
I'm not judging people
other than I'm asking people
and I'm bringing up a different debate
that isn't being talked about a lot
which is why do you
want to go to Coachella?
That's what I'm interested in.
(gentle music)